Right
David Maxwell,
I scored the Zeros percentile for
conscientious in the 84th for
neuroticism.
How do I improve these scores?
Well,
okay,
so the first thing David you might want
to think about is like if all of your
scores were low,
then there's some possibility that
you're being too hard on yourself.
And what I would recommend Danny's get a
couple of friends to fill out the
questionnaire for,
for you to describe you and then see if
first of all,
if there's any agreement to see if
they've.
They are easier on you than you are
yourself.
So,
but let's assume that you are rather low
in conscientiousness.
The next question would be,
well how young are you?
Because younger people tend to be
lowered conscientiousness,
so if you're like 16,
well that's low but it's not
catastrophic.
If you're like 40 and you're not
depressed and zero is,
you know that's low
anyways.
If you are that low in
conscientiousness,
one of the things I would recommend is
a,
make a plan and be learn how to use a
schedule a calendar and do it badly to
begin with,
like electronic calendar,
like Google calendar,
that's the best thing I know of,
to improve conscientious,
to make a plan so that you've got
something to a mat and um,
use a scheduler and maybe you have to,
you know,
talk to someone to help keep you on
track.
Now the other question would be,
do you have other personality traits
that are really high,
like openness because if you're really
high in openness,
then it might be that you're more
inclined towards being motivated by
spontaneous interest and in the artistic
direction.
And if you're really high in
extroversion,
then you're going to be motivated by
being around people you know.
So it also may be that in order to be
conscientious about something,
you have to pick a domain that you're
suited to like socializing or artistic
endeavor and try to work on being
conscientious in those domains.
So that's it.